[Music]
hello and welcome to ear biscuits I'm
Ellie I'm Lizzy and we are back with
some more celebrity conspiracies we got
to talk to rhettandlink about some of
our favorites
Jana Reeves is immortal and Lindsay
Lohan has a twin
Roy was killed by Disney of course but
now we're back with our even more
favorites and we get to delve into a
little bit more detail on these theories
today before we get into anything I just
want to say to you and also to all the
millions of people that I assume are
listening million is that I am NOT an
investigative journalist and I'm gonna
get some of this information wrong I'm
just going to tell you that right now
but the great thing about conspiracy
theories is that most people who dig
into these are not professionals
oh no if you can tell by the quality of
most YouTube videos about this subject
yeah but we like and I would also like
to say before we start that in the the
world of conspiracy theories is large
and wide and sometimes troubling we like
to focus on ones that we think are fun
and plausible I don't know that mine is
fun well that's it does involve aliens
and aliens are fun yeah you're right I
mean they're also sad at times but you
know there's are sad at times I just
feel like sometimes I'll I'll get on a
conspiracy theory thread and it'll be
like aliens are real and I'm like yes
I'm with you and then it's like also the
Queen of England is a lizard and I'm
like yes love it tell me more and then
it's like all of this one race are bad
and I'm like no no no no so sometimes it
gets dicey but we're gonna stay away
from that don't worry about that we're
not gonna stay away from lizards or
aliens though I think conspiracy
theories are all about having fun and
digging out the truth where it's been
hidden it's actually under lizards don't
trust them found tress lizards don't
trust goats what I know that weird
sideways eyes okay we can talk about
this later but I like goats I don't
dislike goats I'm just saying don't
trust them okay I hear you have
something to tell me about yeah I'm
gonna start okay and I want to introduce
you to Lena
gana ringabel wait I actually feel like
I have heard that name before why I'm
probably a conspiracy theory interest i
am i'm merced of a truther no I'm not
I'm not
let's not use that yeah that is a
problem but you do like the truth I do
period full stop and Lina Morgana was a
young woman from Staten Island born to
Russian immigrants who got tangled in a
web with another young woman named
Stephanie Germanotta okay I know who
that is is that ring a bell
yeah cuz that's Lady gaga true or is
Lady gaga
Lena Morgana and is Lena Morgana
actually Lady gaga that's what we're
gonna be talking about okay so basically
the theory here is that Lady Gaga might
have brutally murdered a young aspiring
pop singer in New York to steal her
identity and use that to rocket her to
success of course and a couple couple
problems in this theory there are parts
of it that I think are actually quite
plausible because on the road to fame
there's there's a lot of evil things
that go down right how else do you make
a dress out of meat other than by the
person whose identity you of us yeah it
was not cuts from a local deli no but I
do think something some parts are
possible some aren't so I'm just gonna
lay out the the basic timeline of events
okay and go into where things get a
little dicey okay and I don't know any
of this yet so I'm pretty excited okay
so in 2007 there's this New Jersey
producer named Rob Fusari he's a big
player in this conspiracy theory okay
he was a producer who'd worked with huge
acts like Destiny's Child Will Smith and
Beyonce he was well known in the
community and he was looking for fresh
talent and he in his own words he was
trying to create a female version of The
Strokes
watch and he wound up with lady gaga
well yeah so a couple turns haven't
quite hit his mark well he was actively
looking for talented vocalists and
performers and so between 2007 or 2006
and 2008 he found discovered Lina
Morgana and a mutual friend introduced
him to Stephanie Germanotta which is
what she wasn't Lady Gaga yet okay time
right she's at NYU and my York brown
hair playing on her keyboard in like
thigh high boots I've seen the YouTube
videos yeah yeah
many people have it's it's in the
creation of Lady gaga
in all of the official accounts you
won't really see Rob through saris name
and there's a couple reasons for that
but one might be because she murdered
this lady of course so both of these
women were independently working with
Rob Fusari as talent that he'd found and
and they were basically they allegedly
recorded and wrote together upwards of
10 11 12 songs way all three of them or
all three of them oh so there is a song
and you can look it up and listen to it
I don't think we can legally play it no
but there's a song that got released the
only Lena Morgana official release where
she's singing lead and Lady Gaga
Stephanie Germanotta is singing backup
what it's called Wonderland mmm
with a you wears so wonderland Underland
wonderland like the underworld or like
the germans but like wunderkind yeah
okay I don't know any German but I think
that's a word yeah so obviously Lady
Gaga has a goal of Fame right mm-hm
so probably singing backup vocals didn't
love that all this chick Lena Morgana is
singing lead and getting the main credit
that didn't sit right and that came out
in 2007
somewhere between June of 2007 and
August of 2008 things shifted and Lady
Gaga rose to prominence got signed by
Interscope and released the fame in
August of 2008 okay yes
in October of 2008 Lena Morgana fell off
the roof of Staten Island hotel to her
death of alleged suicide
yikes wait so this happens after Lady
Gaga has come to prominence and Lady
Gaga's released an album right afterward
but wouldn't you think they'd they'd
offer before she released the album well
I think that is a great point and a huge
reason why this theory is doesn't super
hold up water um I feel like maybe she
was sad it's possible and and and the
sad truth is that the obviously the most
likely series of events is that one was
one had the stuff and one didn't or one
was chosen and one wasn't and the the
crushing defeat of having a dream and it
not working out would result in
depression and then suicidal thoughts
and then suicidal action but that didn't
happen what happened is that Lady Gaga
pushed her off a roof right like boo boo
kitty and Empire I'm sorry if anybody
watches Empire I don't think anyone does
anymore I spoiled it's really just yeah
it's just me and I love it and I will
not stop watching Empire I will watch it
until the day so I'm hearing there are
so many good shows Lucy no there's only
one and it's Empire even though it has
jumped the shark in an insane way okay
so so sorry I'm diverging from the main
timeline you'll notice that we will jump
around and it will be frustrating but
it's all to what it used to it so so she
died there was no questions about her
death being by suicide there were
alleged witnesses who saw a woman
dancing erratically on the roof before
she threw herself off oh and hit a
construction scaffolding no that's a
bummer
yeah in this time so Lady Gaga releases
the fame she's a new artist it blows up
right and she releases The Fame Monster
almost a year later and this is when
Lady Gaga we all know and love her and
and we're listening to Just Dance
ad nauseam sure I was in college I
remember this all these things are
happening and the official narrative is
that Lady Gaga was discovered by Akon
and brought into Interscope Records and
when asked about her her persona Lady
Gaga says that she's always been Lady
gaga
but she she only took on the name later
and Rob Fusari claims that she that he
gave her that he gave her that name Lady
Gaga developed the persona with her at
the same time that he was working with
Lena Morgana
and like the club key sorry the club kid
scene at the time was all about wigs and
insane outfits right and stuff like that
and there are actually several artists
that claimed that she stole their look
but Lena Morgana's mother comes out a
year a year after her death maybe two
years and says that Lady Gaga
intentionally stole Lena's look and
sound and like image to become famous
and um this claim was from a grieving
with her and she also said that Lady
Gaga stole her soul as one does when you
when you want to become a famous Terr
correct yeah and stealing someone's soul
is obviously not something that super
holds up in court so this didn't really
go anywhere but her mother said she
didn't want to sue for any money she
just wanted Lena Morgana's music to be
released as I say she wanted Lena
Morgana's soul back she wanted that too
but she wasn't going to push for it um
sure
she just wanted Lena's music to be
really her solo I'm sure was in the
music you know how well that's that's
the point of music obviously I am a
little confused though so she the claim
is that Lady Gaga stole this woman
identity basically that's from the
mother okay
so I'll say that this argument this part
this prong of the conspiracy theory
doesn't really hold water with me
personally because okay first of all
lots of artists repackage reuse get
inspiration from artists of different
generations with varying degrees of
legality within that that happens all
the time
Lena Morgana from everything that I've
seen and lift up and researched was not
doing anything new there's this pretty
funny compilation of pictures of Lena
juxtaposed with pictures of Lady gaga
where they like look really similar but
it's like like Lady Gaga like standing
like this and Lena Morgana like standing
like this I have my hands up my hips and
it's just a very normal pose but they
both have dark hair yeah okay problem
solved they both have dark hair both
have dark character identity no one else
can have dark hair no yeah none of those
really hold water to me I think there's
a lot of more credibility with certain
other artists who claimed that she stole
their like creative characters to become
Lady gaga not Lena Morgana okay but so
what where does the like conspiracy come
in okay the conspiracy comes in with Rob
Fusari so they were actually in a
relationship Lady Gaga and Rob okay yes
so he met Lena Morgana first when she
was really young sorry my mouth just
like farted and I think it was audible
in the microphone so I apologize too can
we go back and make that louder that
heard that I'll do it again if I can oh
no that was that was a little poop but
it wasn't what it did before I wanna do
know poot myself it's fine alright poot
yeah it's fine as in Putin yeah I said
well no don't
he's definitely listening because of my
half of this podcast which we'll get to
in a minute well
okay so Rob Fusari and Lady gaga were
actually in a relationship that
developed sometime between 2007 and 2008
when she met him and they created a
company called like love child LLC um
and the theory here is that he was
working with both Lady gaga and Lina
Morgana together he was also in a
relationship with Lina Morgana but she
was underage Oh gross I know Rob Fusari
not a great guy um and claims of his
like creating Lady gaga
I mean you'll see this pop up all the
time with powerful women that there were
like men who were like I actually did
that um yeah that have very dubious
credibility sure so so the theory is
that he was also romantically involved
with the underage Lina Morgana Lady gaga
knew that she might he might be a
springboard for her and they were in a
romantic relationship
Lina caught feelings was really jealous
she's on tape saying that she would
literally do anything to become a famous
singer and so there's no it's just muddy
the year between 2007 and 2008 what
happened why Lina went from leading from
singing lead to Lady gaga
releasing the fame also weird that Lady
Gaga seems to have covered up any
connection to this guy and this woman
right like that you're saying that's not
their names aren't really listed
altogether on a lot of things well Rob
who's already technically has a producer
credit on the fame okay um but like as
for his lawsuit against her where he
claims to have created her and and all
these things that never really went
anywhere okay um so in that time
something happened where Lina went from
from feature to you know on the street
didn't get signed erratically dancing on
top of a hotel okay and I think the
conspiracy here is just that the
entertainment industry is awful hard
vicious and it can break someone's soul
down but the other conspiracy here is
that this was all actually a very well
constructed
Illuminati sacrifice yes this is what I
wanted to hear about so so I wanted to
give them the most normal ones I wanted
to give the most normal one sort of
their due but is illuminati sacrifice if
you if you check out the YouTube page
know like truth now or whatever I'm not
gonna give you the real one cuz it's
let's go it's about sound of a lot of
things I wouldn't agree with but but
they put it together that Lady Gaga was
actually participating in an Illuminati
sacrifice to get her fame so this is
really common in Illuminati theorists um
Lady Gaga does a ton of the all-seeing
eye stuff and I'm sorry I just covered
my mouth she does this and she she does
a ton of the the sixth the 666 yeah also
I'd like to point out that her wig that
she's wearing in is it the fame monster
where she has the white that looks like
a triangle yeah and we all know the main
triangles belong to the Illuminati so
you can see it all over her work there's
a very strong case that she's in the
Illuminati and this was an Illuminati
sacrifice um most clearly depicted in
her music video for paparazzi where
she's like making out with Alexander
Skarsgard who always plays a convincing
bad guy and her like takes her to the
balcony and they're kissing and then all
sudden it's she gets pushed off the
balcony and falls and they and they
focus on that and a big and it's like
black and white and it's like oh the
fall it's this it's the sacrifice thing
and in the Illuminati view it's all
about secret messaging and this is a not
so secret message of like look I did
this thing I've sacrificed make me huge
and she did isn't it also there's
there's so many theories that like they
make this stuff public and they make it
apparent and in music videos it's kind
of like a like I did this and I'm not
even hiding it and you can yeah it's not
like the Illuminati meets at a round
table of dim lighting you know I think
they do I mean I think some do but it's
a huge network of super powerful people
that right it's like I think we get a
lot of comments of like do you guys
actually believe this and it's like no
but also yes yeah I wouldn't you believe
that this insane world is it's garnered
I think the Illuminati's fun and I like
to believe for the fun of it and also I
definitely believe in it
go watch the what's the Katy Perry music
video wide awake yeah homework
assignment for all of you out there go
watch that video and tell me that
there's not a ton of Illuminati and
MKULTRA mind control yeah so because
there's not a big enough table to bring
in everyone who's ever been inducted to
the Illuminati because they killed
someone right you have to create public
secret messaging and then that gets you
that unlock certain things it's like
Scientology you just become like a
higher thetan but in Scientology sorry
and a lot of money to be a higher right
yeah or painblood right yeah or just
scrub the floor with some toothbrushes
for Scientology right and that sorry
if anybody's no I'm not I'm sorry I'm
not gonna apologize the Scientologists
the worst yeah yeah
so basically did Lady gaga kill Alena
Morgana probably not did she sacrifice
Lina Morgana for the Illuminati gods
absolutely yes
okay all right I like that all right
well I'm super excited to tell you about
my conspiracy which does involve the
holy grail of conspiracy theories aliens
but before we get to that I wanted to
show you something even cooler than
aliens are you ready yes okay oh wow
it's our new good mythical summer tank
top wow it is cooler than aliens also I
wore it in an Instagram post where I'm
like really sweaty and dirty and
disgusting and the comments on it we're
all about how cool the tank top was and
not about how repulsive the amount of
dirt and sweat on my body was so hey you
guys want to distract people from your
sweaty disgusting bod or the truth about
your tank top it'll work for you like it
worked for me
speaking of things that people have been
wondering if they exist for years and
years and years
this new and cool t-shirt oh my gosh it
says I want my GMM I always wondered if
there was gonna a an MTV inspired good
mythical morning t-shirt and now it has
Illuminati been confirmed yeah I slept
on it if you look in here mm-hmm
triangle that's an Illuminati triangle
yeah don't get it twisted we are part of
the family right that's our subliminal
messaging to you I hope you enjoyed it
and if you want to purchase these
beautiful tank tops t-shirts sunglasses
or towels as part of your initiation
ceremony you can find them at
rhettandlink.com/store oh yeah all right
now that we've absolutely killed that
promo like Lady Gaga killed that lady
Hey okay so before we even get into this
I just want to say that I am proceeding
forward assuming that the CIA is
listening to this podcast how huge get
yeah great we're big fans thank you for
coming right thank you for being here
I assume they're also listening to all
of my phone conversations which I'd like
to apologize for I'll try to bring you
more interesting subject matter in the
future
lots of deliberating about which
restaurant to go to yea which restaurant
and also like how much I want to pay for
my cat's medical bills is like that's
probably 90% of the phone call take all
my money it's fine I would just like to
say to those of you in the CIA who are
listening that I'd like to ask that you
just add the word allegedly to the
beginning of every sentence I'm about to
say I feel that legally that should
cover me from here on out I allegedly
believe everything I'm about to say but
does that mean that I really do
allegedly are we cool now I think we are
so cool with me
excellent I'm not gonna see you you it's
not about you I'm not afraid of you I'm
not afraid of the CIA either you guys
seem great so first things first
Ellen Monroe you know beauty icon
talented actress you probably heard of
her before someone in the comments on
the makeup shrade's video with Gabi and
chachi said that I have the face for
Marilyn Monroe look and I was like wow
no one agrees with you but that's not
true you did actually look really good
with the Marilyn Monroe makeup thank you
welcome and you didn't have to get a lot
of plastic surgery to look like that
yeah surgery but that's a different
discussion nothing wrong with plastic
surgery no no she was wrong with your
own face so Marilyn tragically died at
36 years old in beautiful Brentwood Los
Angeles the death was ruled a suicide
the death was ruled a suicide but as
with all celebrity deaths there are
other theories as to what happened of
course of course you're not a real
celebrity if people don't trust your no
no like Elvis didn't die he's an alien
Jim Morrison is partying on a beach
somewhere and well dates will never die
Keanu Reeves will never die
the sad part about this is that no part
of this theory involves Marilyn still
being alive so that was misleading but
here we go now for years there have been
conspiracies that she may have been
murdered as opposed to having tragically
taken her own life but just this year a
new conspiracy emerged about why she may
have been murdered and that's what I
would like to tell you about today okay
that's great because I have heard that
she might have been murdered right and
having known no details about it I've
been like yes for sure true right that
well of course because I think what is
at the base of all these celebrity
conspiracy theories especially with ones
that are about like celebrities still
being alive or you know like something
you you want to believe that something
other than the tragic probable reality
is is what happened so I think that's
what Spurs a lot of these but as we've
said previously this does involve our
friends from space aka the aliens I love
them I love them too I feel like they're
nice I feel like if they showed up I
would be that lady in men in black who's
on the top of the US Bank tower
do you like welcome she does get blown
up so I hope that that's not what
happens well humans have famously
depicted aliens as evil throughout time
that's a conspiracy yeah I don't think
they are I feel like we're the bad ones
and the aliens are showing up and going
oh no and just turning around and
leaving yeah
picture alien covenant directed by
Ridley Scott that just came out recently
but then the human beings that are in it
are actually the aliens and the aliens
that are like are actually us like
that's what we are basically so that's a
whole other podcast that we can get to
another time because I have a lot to say
on aliens but the first thing I want to
get out of the way with this is that
Marilyn was a hot mess like that is not
debated anywhere she was a this is on
hot yeah very hot but a total mess she
had a history of drug and alcohol abuse
she was treated really badly by so many
of the studios that she worked with and
what I'm getting at is like yeah it is
highly possible that something very sad
and not at all suspicious happened here
but there is some weird stuff that could
suggest otherwise so we're gonna go down
that rabbit hole right now remember the
whole like happy birthday mr. president
thing like really embarrassing so for
those of you who don't know what we're
talking about Marilyn Monroe performed
at a birthday party for John F Kennedy
and she sang happy birthday to him and
it was very provocative and everybody
was really uncomfortable as she was
doing it yeah think about when I just
did it just then but like so much warmer
and worse somehow worse and not really
what you want to be watching it the
president's birthday party but whatever
that occurred about three months before
Marilyn died whoa yeah I didn't know
that yeah yeah very recent too when she
died so that brings us to the middle of
this mess because what's at the middle
of this is the fact that she was
absolutely 100% definitely having an
affair with JFK which this is not even
debated at this point for real yeah no I
mean not have heard about it but I
didn't know that people were like yeah
that was definitely Ono there are like
pictures of them together I mean there's
yeah there there's no doubt that she was
I spent too much time on the
conspiracies of the early aughts and
need to get into this no yeah there's so
much to this so the level of the affair
is hotly debated because some people say
oh it was just a couple of encounters it
wasn't like a big deal nobody really
cared other people are like no it was
very serious she was very much in love
with him
he was very hot I guess I don't I always
thought bobby was hotter but this is not
about which kennedy is hotter although
let us know if you think they're both
hot and powerful right
she herself seemed to think that it was
relatively serious because there are
friends of hers that have gone on record
saying that she wanted to become the
first lady so like she had a game plan
was it a solid game plan no this was not
something she should have embarked after
she you're gonna love this she
reportedly called the White House spoke
to Jackie oh whoa yeah
told her about the affair and admitted
that she wanted to marry JFK and Jackie
O had no I know Jackie Oh had the best
possible response this is according to a
book that was released relatively
recently she said I wish I could do
Jackie O's accent but I think I would
you'd have to like Natalie Portman No
then we'll try I wish I could do Jackie
O's accent I can't I might try and do
Natalie Portman's bad Jackie O accent
we'll see I'm gonna read it normally
first so Jackie O said that's great and
you'll move into the White House and
you'll assume the responsibilities of
the first lady and I'll move out and
you'll have all the problems which is
the best response Wow yeah Savage yeah
she was really well deserved though yeah
she was like you want this you have it
good yeah it's a nice man that being a
politician's wife was a nightmares job
yeah and also like oh you just get like
you just have to like go to appearances
no it's a total nightmare and to wear
cardigans all the time right yeah he's
also pretty young a very young I mean
they they both were Jackie oh wow what a
response she was pretty awesome
so wait who says that that conversation
happened that is from a book
let me see that's from a book that was
released relatively recently and that is
a friend that said that friend of Jackie
O's or maryland's why are you
questioning my sources I love it so much
I wanna know I don't know where it came
from
well put a link hold on I just started
typing natalie portman instead of Jackie
oh that's the Illuminati in my brain the
natalie portman Illuminati which is
she's definitely in the Illuminati just
her zach braff and whoever her like
weird director husband okay here we here
we go here we go
Oh No her husband's on a director he's a
ballet dancer you know that way then
damn raped my son Natalie Portman no
that's the guy who's dating Jennifer
Lawrence no really yeah Jacobs shaking
his head yes yeah okay it's it's a book
called these few precious days the final
year of Jack with Jackie so does a book
that focuses on Jackie and JFK I have
not read it so I'm not gonna say that
it's good or that you should read it it
might be garbage it might be great sure
but full-time jobs in addition to this
right yes we skim the articles don't
have time to read full things okay let
me get back to where we were here we go
okay so yes so Marilyn was not keeping
this a secret here's where here's where
it gets a little crazy pants
Marilyn didn't just have an affair with
JFK she was also having an affair with
his brother Bobby Kennedy Wow best of
both worlds baby
yeah the timeline is iffy not scary
world yeah not a world you should be
dipping your toes in to this the affair
is not sure if they were simultaneous or
not the timeline is very iffy let's just
say it was probably a weird time for
everybody there might have been some
awkward family dinners they are the
on record from what I know of her ugly
husbands the the most attractive of
people that she I don't think Joe
DiMaggio was ugly it's just kind of kind
of weird-looking yeah but we're looking
has never been synonymous with as heck
like Bob okay fair enough yes I like I
understand now Marilyn had a habit of
going out and getting a little toasted
at parties and talking about JFK and
Bobby which obviously didn't throw the
people who were in charge of national
security the CIA so since she was
doubling Boston scandal we get it yeah
this is basically an episode of scandal
now since she was she was doubling down
on her Kennedy fun times she became a
person of interest to the CIA which
brings me to the fact that they were
wire tapping her phone conversations for
real yes for real and this this is like
they were wiretapping her conversations
some people believe she's being
monitored as early as 1955 which
actually could potentially predate these
affairs with enemies which is
interesting so I don't know if that's
the case but that's one theory now here
is where the aliens come in and I bet
you thought we would never get to them
I've been waiting for them page arrived
my friend a documentary was released
this year called unacknowledged and it
follows dr. Steven Greer who's the
founder of the disclosure project in his
quest to expose the fact that aliens
exist and the government totes knows
about it love it yeah it I did actually
watch this whole documentary and I have
to say I don't necessarily recommend
that you watch it only because the
opening credits are a relatively
upsetting montage of just every bad
thing that's ever happened as far as I
can tell yeah it's set to like Louie
Armstrong singing what a wonderful world
that's it's too much rude it's too much
that's rude and uncalled they show the
like the guy in front of the tank in
Tiananmen Square and then and then an
alien and you're like I don't I don't
connect the dots here but I just heard
about aliens I wasn't trying to like sob
into my breakfast I'd like to point out
that they don't totally connect the dots
of that montage either okay so in this
documentary dr. Steven or Steve as I'm
gonna call him
close personal friend dr. Steve alien
man whips out a CIA memo about a wiretap
that concerns Marilyn Monroe
now the memo is dated August 3rd 1962
she died August 5th in 1962
whoa yeah so this is two days before she
died now the memo indicates a record of
a wiretapped conversation between
Dorothy kill Guerin who was an
investigative reporter who was among
other things looking into Roswell and
area 51 she sounds cool she actually is
really cool and had a bunch of
involvement in the lives of the Kennedys
and some other things we won't get too
much into her but I will say that she
also died very mysterious
so it's gonna be my question yes she
died very mysteriously shortly after
Maddy my girl after JFK was killed I
believe she was found dead because she'd
been looking heavily into his
assassination
so she's interesting look her up anyway
this is a record of a wire tapped
conversation between her and her friend
Howard Rothberg in which they are
discussing a conversation between
Marilyn Monroe and Bobby Kennedy as far
as I can tell this is this is a the memo
concerns both wiretaps of Monroe and
Kennedy and kill Guerin and Rothberg but
I am NOT a wiretap scientist and
honestly it was very confusing so I'd
just like to drop an inception boom here
and say that it was a wiretap inception
because I don't totally understand why
you know what you know from what I've
heard from you just now I'm gonna accept
that great that's great as long as
you're ok with it with that there is
several wiretaps involved in this memo
I'll leave it there
now the memo states that Monroe had been
repeatedly calling the Kennedys
specifically Bobby Kennedy and
complaining that Bobby and Jack had both
been ignoring her and she was getting
angry he sounds like me after any
breakup exactly she's mad
they aren't returning her calls they are
ghosting her she was threatening to hold
a press conference
literally yeah she starts threatening to
hold a press conference if they don't
return her calls and this is where it
gets dicey in this press conference she
intended to divulge several JFK's
secrets including a secret military base
in Cuba and assassination attempts
against Castro now those happened most
importantly she was going to talk about
Kennedy's visit
to a quote secret airbase for the
purpose of inspecting things from outer
space Wow yeah and that was the big
outer space is not a code art no and
this is well before moon landing this is
you know 1962 and dr. Greer alien man
believes this is referring to the
remains of the 1947 Roswell crash Wow we
could do an entire episode of Roswell as
well because it is truly fascinating and
they're almost certainly was something
weird that crashed there unclear what it
was but yeah the greatest celebrity of
all is the aliens that we've never seen
I know and apparently they were like
little and some of them didn't survive
the crash
nobody's they didn't make it in their
interplanetary journey but it sounds
like maybe JFK paid their little bodies
a little visit you think a nice one yeah
I don't think he was like poking at
their bodies being like they didn't do
anything bad all right so of course this
would be a huge national security issue
if she were to reveal this information
not to mention the fact that it would
make Kennedy's let's all go to the moon
campaign a little weirder if people are
like wait a minute you're sending our
people to the moon but you know about
these little little alien men that
landed in Roswell okay right so uh but
if they're little it's like what's there
to be afraid of that's what I think
they sound tiny and adorable by all of
the accounts I watched all these
accounts of I guess that's what happens
right before you get your head eat
enough it's really it's so cute
all the people talking about Roswell I
watched documentaries of these like
burly air force men folks but we will
watch documented documentary but they're
talking about the little aliens and
they're like I thought it was a human
child then I got close to it just had
like a big head and its arms were a
little too long I was wearing like a
little gray suit that kind of looked
like skin but wasn't and I'm like like a
bodycon dress like what Kim Kardashian
wears where it's kind of a TV movie
exactly a musical so if you need to
picture the aliens picture them wearing
what Miley was wearing it
your arm was in a bigger head she
actually does have a big head in long
arms though so that might add up new
theory Miley Cyrus is one of the aliens
that crashed at Roswell Miley Cyrus at
some point thought that she was for sure
so one thing about the memo it surfaced
in the 90s and when it did dr. Donald R
Burleson author of UFOs in the murder of
Marilyn Monroe Oh a classic right
everybody is right on the money
yeah he didn't pull any punches there
filed an appeal under the Freedom of
Information Act to have the CIA released
the wiretap of Marilyn Monroe's phone
and he based this appeal very heavily on
the information in this memo now the CIA
could have just said that's a pile of
fake garbage we were never wiretapping
her phones that memo is not real but
they didn't do that they accepted the
appeal yeah so did the transcripts end
up getting released
no but the appeal request was accepted
initially so that potentially indicates
that this transcript Israel Wow one more
thing about the memo real quick on the
document allegedly according to one very
tin hat blog that I found there was some
bleed through of ink from another
document that had been sitting on top of
this document something that had been
filed away with it
the name Brigadier General George
Sheldon appears to have bled through in
the upper left-hand corner of the
document this is important because
George Shogun was a big-time important
Air Force man who had been linked by a
ton of theorists to the investigations
surrounding the crash at Roswell so
either a secretary was slipping a little
brandy in her coffee or they thought
that this memo was important enough and
connected enough to Roswell that they
filed it with something of his a report
of his what have we learned so far just
to recap JFK was a terrible bedtime
secret keeper and the Kennedys were the
original ghost errs right yes yeah don't
date them and you can't so you know also
I think if Maryland had I have time is
linear right you're right it is a flat
circle
I apologize I also think that if Marilyn
had had access to an iPhone with read
receipts this would have gone very
differently because she could have taken
screenshots and been like I know you're
looking at my texts and they would
been like you're right we are looking at
them and we just don't want to be with
you and then she probably would have
been like that stinks but I'm moving on
my famous actress is very powerful right
she might have been okay moral of the
story is return people's text messages
just you know man up and reply no
question and then if aliens come it's
not a matter of national security to
keep them hidden just let us know it
might be a matter of national security
I don't trust everybody I trust I trust
me let me know that's all you have to do
I won't talk about it I won't talk about
it either
you can trust both of us although for
sure we're very quiet about these things
so okay two days after this memo is
taken down we are now at oddest fifth
1962 the day that marilyn is found dead
in her Brentwood home at 12 305 fifth
Hellena drive which side note is a very
cute house I looked it up yeah you sent
it to me too it's really cute you
wouldn't tell me anything else you just
send me a link to Marilyn Monroe's house
because it's like so adorable and it's a
little Hacienda and it wasn't that big
and it just that made me sadder than
anything else was seeing her house
because it's really cute so the day
before my house is in Arlen
absolutely not that one only cost five
million dollars so if we start saving
now only if aliens show up and are
confirmed why do you have to be mean to
me I'm not being mean I'm putting this
is an incentive for the CIA to reveal
aliens to us they want us to buy a house
together and the only way that'll happen
is if they reveal the existence of alien
just me throwing someone out there and
you hurting my feelings wrong I hope
I'll buy a house can't even
theoretically buy a houses
I can't theoretically involve myself
financially with anyone I'll rent it
with you how's that
I don't know you can it's fine you can
visit I'll buy one maybe sometime
whatever all right so the day before she
died Marilyn spoke with several friends
and spent the day with her therapist dr.
Greenwood who by the way seems like
big-time creep no no
yeah he was weird and spent the day with
her housekeeper as well so her house has
her housekeeper is weird and there I'm
gonna say small-time creep and there are
some theories that the housekeeper and
the therapist were both involved in this
because they're the only two that are
around when the shiz goes down oh boy
by the way I would call Rob Fusari
big-time creep yeah I would call Lina
Morgana's mom small-time creep oh yeah I
would agree with that yeah I mean so
yeah I'm gonna qualify dr. Greenwood is
big-time creep and housekeeper as
small-time creep the housekeeper ends up
spending the night with Marilyn to keep
her company okay and is that normal it
is not weird weird weird my my spidey
senses are tingling right your
conspiracy theory senses are tingling so
at around 8:30 p.m. Marilyn goes to bed
and that's the last anyone ever seen
since early it is early the housekeeper
claims that at 3:00 a.m. she woke up
because she sensed something was wrong
and when she went to check on Marilyn
the door was locked so I always wake up
in the middle and right and I'm like ah
something's wrong right let me check on
my boss uh well I've woken up in the
middle of the night to be like oh I just
had a weird dream
oh I need water whatever been like the
person in the next room is in trouble I
sometimes wake up and I'm like is
someone trying to get in my windows and
then all are also exceedingly I know
I'll walk the perimeter of my house and
check all my windows at 4:00 in the
morning sometimes so if you see me
walking around my house really safe well
yeah it doesn't take me very long to do
a lab how she meets one bedroom
apartment hey it's you know I fit which
is really hard to get in Los Angeles
yeah she's doing accomplishment I got it
real cheap they're definitely not so all
right so here's what here's what the
housekeeper does she
her spidey senses tingle and she senses
something is wrong right she goes to
check on Marilyn the door is locked but
the light is on so she thinks that's
weird
does she call the police or a doctor no
she calls the therapist where it's
me is weird because you know and some
argument might be like well they were
worried about Maryland's mental health
she was distressed they call the
therapist it's like no if it's 3:00 a.m.
and you're concerned about your friend
slash employers a possible desire to off
themselves you call the police
yeah and also I'll say like it's okay to
be the type of person who like like
tries a door and it's locked and it's
like oh maybe they're having private
time you know whatever but it's not okay
to be that type of person and the type
of person who wakes up in the middle of
the night and it's like I think I think
something's wrong with my friend right
now like it called the people who can
actually do something about this I mean
I don't know I mean it doesn't have an
axe to break down the door no and like
maybe I understand but yeah I it's weird
and also there are some allegations that
he may have been having an affair with
her as well so it's strange oh wait the
therapist with the housekeeper no with
Marilyn yeah so that that's that's weird
and that's not super confirmed but he
was he was a creep so any big-time creep
big time creepy though she calls the
therapist the therapist shows up can't
get into the room he goes outside breaks
a window goes into the room and finds
Marilyn deceased now official reports
say that she died of ingesting
barbiturates and that it was intentional
on her part a couple of weird things
about the situation number one which
we've already discussed why do you call
the therapist number two she was in a
relatively developed state of rigor
mortis which this is gross everyone I
apologize but why is it that these
details are like my favorite details and
they're also the grossest eat well cuz
they're interesting I mean it she she
was she was in rigor mortis I just
burped I'm sorry everyone um for those
of you who don't know I have really
frothy weird burps yeah there's a
someone once referred to them as Nescafe
froth a burps yeah don't trust me I'm
definitely an alien I wish I knew I
would sell them so she'sshe's in rigor
mortis which means that she had been
dead for quite some time this is at 3:00
a.m. that they're showing up which means
that she had to have died almost
immediately
after she went in her room and closed
the door at 8:30 p.m. immediately maybe
that's why she went to bed so early
she's I hope I can feel it coming on you
gotta go now I mean that might be a real
thing yes 100% that could be a real
thing but she did also have a phone
conversation with her ex-husband Joe
DiMaggio's son at like 7:30 p.m. before
she went to bed and he said everything
was fine
and she didn't seem strange didn't seem
weird which people say all the time
that's not necessarily an indicator that
everything is okay but he did say he
didn't notice anything some other
strange things which would be because
you would have had to take it right
after right after right after like it's
like media yeah yes literally let me
take down two bottles of this stuff yeah
so it's another weird thing she had a
couple of weird bruises one on her hip
and one on her lower back these are
still unexplained to be honest I think
relatively big and noticeable but like I
have huge bruises on me all the time so
if I ever turn up dead I'd probably just
hit a table you're just like a look at
your leg and you're like what happened
yes I have like what looks like
fingerprint marks on me which I can only
assume is because I'm being visited by a
ghost but it has not disrupted my life
thus far so it's fine there also weren't
any needle marks reported in the initial
autopsy and it was said that she hadn't
and she had ingested the pills orally
but initially there were no pills
reported in her stomach what yes she
also didn't okay any of the yellow
residue that apparently occurs with this
kind of pill now the guy who did the
autopsy who I'll get to in a minute came
back later and said you know no no like
everyone's misinterpreting this that
would actually be very common for a
habitual pill user to not have the pills
in their stomach it would have been
absorbed quickly yada yada yada what
it's a weird explanation and it's also
debated as that if whether or not that's
actually real next we were debated by
like other medical professionals because
I would love to know yeah it's I mean
that that is something that conspiracy
theorists tend to cling to in this case
the other thing he only runs a
toxicology report on her blood and
her liver not her other organs and when
they did this two different drugs
appeared both of which are well known
they were well above the amount needed
to kill someone like way above Wow
and the mortician who performed the
autopsy Thomas Noguchi he's important
felt like he had Bar name in your last
name now buddy yeah well he's a hit
you'll see he's a famous mortician so he
felt that he had botched the autopsy by
not testing the rest of her organs okay
so two weeks later he went back and
asked to run reports on the other organs
and he was informed that it was too late
and they had already been disposed of
another weird thing normally with a
high-profile case like this the chief
medical examiner would have been the one
to perform the autopsy like this is the
sex symbol of 1960s she's died and they
don't bring the case to the chief
medical examiner they bring it to this
lower level mortician who has not worked
that many cases at this point so that's
so we really weird by the way I I don't
want to break up your energy but I can
tell you're in like in the throes of
getting into your point because you keep
doing this with your chair I got into my
going around because it's about to get
really good it's it's like oh I just hit
my chin on the mic sorry like yeah float
like a butterfly sting like a bee about
just sting like a bee I am it's my dance
because I'm getting to this so no
explanation is ever given for why the
autopsy was handed to a lower level
mortician with much less experience
something else I found interesting as I
was digging into this guy he doesn't
stay lower level for very long he went
on to become the chief medical examiner
by the late 60s and he poaches like
becoming a famous pop star and like for
mortician well yeah this is like
becoming Lady gaga if you are a
mortician yeah and that requires
sacrifice my friend it does and becoming
the chief medical examiner for the city
of Los Angeles to which like famously
corrupt write famously corrupt but also
like a lot of murders so it's a pretty
hard job and it's an important job and
he goes on to become that and he
performed autopsies on everyone from the
Manson
victims to Robert Kennedy himself later
on now here we have arrived at the part
of this story that no one can explain
away Oh Marilyn famously kept a little
red diary and it was in this diary that
she was writing down all of this stuff
that she was learning from JFK and any
little secrets she had anything about
who she'd slept with this this was quite
a book that could have been very
damaging to a lot of full of secrets
about aliens
so the the coroner's office or the
police I can't remember I'm I'm like
blacking out right now one of them finds
this book in her house after she has
died shortly after she's died when
they're you know going through her house
looking for anything suspicious they
find this book it goes into evidence one
day after her autopsy is performed this
book goes missing and it has never
reappeared it has never showed up it's
never all of a sudden been like oh we
found Marilyn's little diary it's up for
auction
no this thing is just gone and the old
lad some problem it's a problem and it's
weird and the only record of that
existing are from her friends being like
yeah I know about this book I know she
had it and I know she was writing
everything down in it and it's just gone
so you know here we are at the end of
this who did it the answer is nobody
knows there are theories that the CIA
killed her because they were afraid that
she was going to expose the alien
information there are theories that they
killed her as a point of pressure on the
Kennedys as in like you see what we can
do if you cross us which may not have
panned out super well for them later on
again allegedly CIA big fan and then
this is the one that I actually don't
buy which is a pretty common theory this
is this theory goes that Bobby Kennedy
was the one that killed her because he
was afraid that she would expose him and
his brother and ruin their political
careers here's why I don't buy this
she was very public about this affair
and so many people knew so many people
knew that Jack makes you look cool no
yeah and like it's not and like
everybody you had an affair with Marilyn
Monroe what a weirdo right and like
everybody knew that JFK had a massive
womanizing habit like that was common
knowledge so I don't totally buy that
they would have been willing to kill
somebody for revealing that information
I'm not buying that so the moral of the
story here is poor Marilyn like I just
think she didn't get it I think she
didn't understand the level of the
information she was dealing with and you
know also just don't discuss proof of
aliens that you've learned in a
president's bed in open settings it
might seem like the best party gossip
but it's not yeah I mean I feel from
Marilyn because I am also bad at keeping
secrets me too mostly we need him so
much tell me about aliens I would start
drinking and just start telling my
friends about it there's little green
man in Roswell I'm sorry they were gray
actually I should be sexually accurate
about that little
yeah I like to think that maybe she's
partying with the aliens now Oh ones who
died in the crash yes I think we're up
there with David Bowie and the little
grey aliens and dynasts the dinosaurs
and that there's we're hanging out on
the space base on the Dark Side of the
Moon which is also real and Leena
Morgana is performing for us
I guess if she has to be there she
actually wasn't that great well yeah she
didn't become the fame monster which is
probably what happened there oh I don't
think I was gonna say about calling
everyone her little monsters when she
herself is the monster oh it would have
been cool in the moment but missed it
yeah well it will come back again I'll
leave you with one last thing which is
that Marilyn's second husband Joe
DiMaggio who she remained close to even
after they divorced okay
does very clearly lay the blame of her
death on the Kennedys
really yes now he doesn't not by like
okay yeah I think I'm gonna answer what
you're about to ask it not
he doesn't say like they specifically
murdered her but he has always said I
know who was responsible for her death I
feel very strongly about it he
apparently ended his friendship with
Frank Sinatra when Frank Sinatra
introduced her to the Kennedys and he
always felt that her becoming involved
in that circle of people and the the mob
ties that were connected there became
her downfall whether or not it was of
her own doing or someone else is doing
that that's unclear how he feels about
that but he he did was not their biggest
fan Wow yeah so there you have it there
you have it Marilyn Monroe knew about
aliens and she had a big mouth
about aliens and that was a mistake and
that's what we've learned today so if
you ever learn something about aliens I
guess keep it to yourself yeah don't
encourage silencing your voice yeah okay
let us tell karpio
yeah which we don't have six six seven
on the Avenue oh yeah that is it
I forgot we opened that up amazing that
it was available yeah you would think
that someone else would have grabbed
that oh yeah all of them and again as we
said previously in our podcast with
rhett and Link we would happily accept
an invite from the Illuminati oh well it
requires mother no it's a rich women let
me know yeah if it's less less the scary
part of Eyes Wide Shut and more the
boring part it's okay actually the whole
thing was weird and kind of boring so no
part of that movie and my aunt on board
I would be a part of any part of it
[Laughter]
so you know I miss the most boring sex
party ever on film it's news which is
amazing it's a snooze of an orgy which
is not how you would think that would go
yeah the only thing that you don't want
that if I'm being honest I feel like
that is if I were to host an orgy that
would be exhausting everyone would leave
feeling bored bored and tired they won't
cut it out yeah I want to say that I I
have I have a very strong theory this is
this is just separate and this is
relevant that Taylor Swift will be
surprised dropping her new album on July
13th 2017 so in three days but just so
you know this is the second time she's
predicted
was for June 16th 2013 June 13th I'm
sorry so I'm expecting you predicted
everything was that I thought it was
because this is her sixth studio album
13 is her lucky number right and it
would have messed with Katy Perry's
first week album sales of her newest
album witness which obviously they're in
a feud but she released an EP called
beautiful eyes and so this this new
album will technically be her seventh
release seven thirteen seventeen doesn't
that roll off the tongue that does and
when it doesn't happen you will find an
eighth release that means that it could
potentially happen
okay so regardless of date I do think
she's gonna pull a Beyonce or Frank
Ocean and just drop it in the middle of
the night with no fanfare blank so - we
don't have the patience with her to have
a full album promo no people are in this
age of Internet they get annoyed with
celebrities too soon it's it's the way
of the past this is the future she's
just gonna want to prove to everyone her
biggest strength which is that she's one
of the best songwriters of all time and
she's also a bad person so oh I fully
know Taylor's wonderful person I love
her I'll support her also to bring this
full circle
she's evil and she's amazing yeah she's
an ice queen and I love her all right
well I think that wraps this up you know
big like you to use CIA for listening
both here on this podcast and to me
while I sleep same here thank you a huge
fan like a true big fans you can find
our videos if you want to watch us
legally on our YouTube channel well
everyone's YouTube channel this is
mythical we have videos that air every
Thursday so please tune in to those
instead of my phone calls yeah we just
did one where we put on makeup on a
mechanical bull and it was a treasure
really hard and my legs were sore for a
full week after work a long time so make
sure you watch that and watch everything
else and this is mythical cuz it's like
pretty fun and stuff and it's it's not
my phone calls again
okay bye
[Music]